معنى ابن جبل لزيتون في القدس مراسلات
الجزيره نجوان سمري نجوان ماذا عن مفاعيل
هذا القرار قرار الحكومه الاسرائيليه سواء
داخل الحكومه او على صعيد ما قد يحدث في
الايام القادمه في هذه العشره الاواخر على
مستوى المسجد الاقصى
نعم عبد القادر دعني فقط اشير الى ان هذا
الصباح كانت الاوضاع هادئه جدا في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك وربما هذه هي المره الاولى
منذ اكثر من اسبوع يؤدي فيها نحو خمسه عشر
الف فلسطينيا صلاه الفجر بعد ان شهدنا عده
ايام من المنع والقيود التي فرضها
الاحتلال على دخول فئه الشبان من هم دون
سن الاربعين لاداء صلاه الفجر خلال
الاسبوع الماضي مضطرهم الى اداء الصلاه
عند الابواب تحديدا في منطقه باب الاسباط
ومنطقه باب حطه لكن هذا اليوم هناك حاله
من الهدوء في المسجد الاقصى وفي البلده
القديمه ولاحظنا ايضا اجراءات لافته
بتخفيف الوجود العسكري والشرطي لقوات
الاحتلال في محيط البلده القديمه
في داخل الازقه هذا يحدث بطبيعه بعد ان
اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو بتعليق
الاقتحامات حتى نهايه شهر رمضان المبارك
ونؤكد ونشير هنا في هذا السياق ان هذا
الاجراء عمليا تماشيا مع الاجراءات
المتبعه منذ عده سنوات وهي ليست خطوه
استثنائيه كما حاولت عده جهات اسرائيليه
ان تصورها بمعنى هذا هو الاجراء المتبع ان
توقف هذه الاقتحامات خلال الايام العشر
الاواخر كانت هناك محاولات من قبل جهات
استيطانيه في السنوات الاخيره الماضيه
لتغيير هذا الوضع وهذا الاجراء وهو ما كان
يؤدي دائما الى اندلاع مواجهات عنيفه
شهدناها في عام 2018 وايضا في السنتين
الماضيتين لذلك اتخذ هذا القرار من قبل
رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو عمليا بان
يتم الالتزام بالاجراء المتبع من عده
سنوات لكن هناك ادانات واسعه لهذا القرار
من قبل جهات يمينيه متطرفه من قبل التيار
الديني الصهيوني في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وجاء ذلك متمثلا بالاعلان او بالبيان الذي
نشره وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي الذي
وصف هذا القرار بالخاطئ وقال بانه
على العكس سيزيد من التصعيد بحسب البيان
الصادر عنه من جهه اخرى منظمات استيطانيه
تطلق على نفسها منظمات الهيكل او منظمات
عائدون الى الهيكل وهي التسميه العبريه
للمسجد الاقصى المبارك ادانت هذا القرار
وقالت بانه قرار غير صحيح
ويجب الاستمرار بهذه الاقتحامات في كل
ايام السنه عبد القادر
شكرا جزيلا لك